His guys
I'm beck by the way
If you have seen this video to please don't skip
Maybe this is the sign
To fulfill your dreams
In the last video I made
Someone there commented about the training center
I have enrolled
Actually guys when is decided to go to the uk
I also really have no idea what
So I asked my aunt a question
They employ non healthcare professionals
Nurses with no prior experience
Or those super durations
Those who did not practice nursing
After training they will help you find an employer
But in my case they are not the ones who looked for my employer
But I'm still thankful for their training
Just a disclaimer,
I'm not connected to ians
I am just sharing what I went through
And where did I enroll
But you can always check your facebook page
And finally decide for yourself
Those I have been with in ils and those I have been with
My volunteer work
The rest of them
They had their caregiving training in tesda
Tesda offered in good training course
That will often use other hcas as well
Being here in the UK or abroad
We also have other training centers
In the Philippines
That provides caregiving courses
But we have to become vigilant
And careful when choosing which center
Because they must be registered to provide the training
I hope this video helps
That's two minutes
Like and follow my videos to get more updates thank you